okay so let me ask a romanticized
question
what to you is one of the most or the
most beautiful combinatorial
algorithm in your own life or just in
general in the field that you've
ever come across or have developed
yourself oh
i like the stable matching problem or
the stable marriage problem
uh very much what's the stable matching
problem
yeah imagine that you
want to marry off end boys
with uh and girls
and each boy has an ordered list of his
preferences among the girls
his first choice is second choice
through her
nth choice and
um
each girl also has a an ordering of the
boys
first choice second choice and so on
and we'll say and we will say that a
matching
one-to-one matching of the boys with the
girls
is stable if there are
no two couples in the matching
such that the boy in the first couple
prefers the girl in the second couple to
her mate
and she refers the boy to her current
mate in other words if there is
the matching is stable if there is no
pair
who want to run away with each other
leaving their partners behind
gosh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah actually this is relevant to
matching residents with hospitals and
some other real life problems
although uh not quite in the form that i
described
so it turns out that there is that a
stable for any set of preferences
a stable matching exists
and moreover it can be computed
by a simple algorithm in which
each boy starts making proposals to
girls
and if the girl receives the proposal
she accepts it tentatively
but she can
drop it if she can end it she can drop
it
later if she gets a better proposal from
her point of view
and the boys start going down their
lists proposing to their first second
third choices
until stopping when
a proposal is accepted
but the girls meanwhile are watching the
proposals that are coming into them
and the girl will drop her current
partner um
if she gets a better proposal and the
the boys never
go back through they never go back yeah
so once they've been
denied they don't try again
they don't they don't they don't try
again because the girls
are always improving their status as
they get more
as they receive better and better
proposals the boys are
going down their list starting with
their top preferences
and
one can prove that
that the process will come to an end
where everybody will get matched with
somebody
and you'll you won't have any pair that
want to
abscond from each other do you find the
proof or the algorithm itself
beautiful or is it the fact that with
the the simplicity of just
the two marching i mean the simplicity
of the underlying rule of the algorithm
is that the beautiful part
both i i would say um and you also have
the observation that
you might ask who is better off the boys
who are doing the proposing or the girls
who are reacting to proposals
and it turns out that it it's the boys
who are doing
the doing the best that is each boy is
doing at least as well
as uh he could do in any other stable
matching
so there's a sort of lesson for the boys
that you should go out and be
proactive and make those proposals
go for broke i don't i don't know if the
this is directly mappable
philosophically to our society but uh
certainly
seems like a compelling notion and
like you said there's probably a lot of
actual real world problems that this
could be mapped to
yeah well you get you you get uh
complications
for example what happens when a husband
and wife want to be assigned to the same
hospital
so you uh you you have to
take those constraints into account and
then the problem becomes
np hard or
uh why is it a problem for the husband
and wife to be assigned to the same
hospital
no it's desirable so desirable or at
least go to the same city
so you can't if you really i think if
you're assigning
residents to hospitals and then you have
some preferences
uh for the husband and wife for for the
hospitals the residents have their own
preferences references
residents both male and female have
their own preferences
um the hospitals have their preferences
but if if
resident a the boy is going to
philadelphia
then you'd like his wife
be also to be assigned to a hospital
in philadelphia so which step makes it a
np-hard problem
that you mentioned the fact that you
have this additional constraint
that it's not just the preferences of
individuals
but the fact that the two partners to a
marriage
have to go to have to be assigned to the
same place
i'm being a little dense uh
the sort of the perfect matching
no not the stable matching is what you
refer to
that's when two partners are trying to
okay what's confusing you is that in the
first
interpretation of the problem i had boys
matching with girls
yes in the second interpretation
you have humans matching with
institutions
and there's a coupling between within
the gotcha within the humans
any added little constraint will make it
an empty heart problem
well yeah okay
by the way the algorithm you mentioned
wasn't was one of yours no no that was
due to
gail and shapley and
my friend david gale passed away before
he could get part of the nobel prize
but his partner shapley uh
shared in a nobel prize with somebody
else for economics
for ideas stemming from this stable
matching idea
you